welcome to this video playing black
black Higgins fritz car Fritz car seven
out of seven out of 11 okay i recently
had good results with this line let's
see if i can check keep that up I can
lost one game against a good good player
but other than that I am squad pretty
well yeah like once to play knight c6 a
5-2 c4 ultimately you have to watch out
for 96 what I just did with Queen g7 and
have to go there anyway for later long
castling
okay sugar I don't know Bishop Bishop e3
I mean this looks nice on a three but
what is what is it doing actually okay 2
c1 2 what does he want to do go into a 6
now I can put the night on c4 anyway
that looks like a good square
okay he probably wants to prepare
castling right or well somehow protect h
fry okay on FY always have night is
seven though so I have seen no reason
okay maybe I should remove here to G to
have hive first I can do that first I
don't need to cancel yet if I cancel you
maybe you could have played Queen f3
Bishop e3 looking at the f7 pond I try
to make sure I'm okay that Mumbai night
at five first gem the position is very
nice long term because of the structure
and the night on c4 so let's say if i
can trade queens not that there is a
direct way to do it but if I could trade
Queens I'm almost winning here on the
queenside long-term it's not so evident
how wide is going to to use as some
ideas on the dark squares and is taking
a while it's really not easy to play I
think black is definitely for choice but
it's probably it's not yet anything
dramatically bad also it's just just
easier to play for black ok let's castle
and go from there I'm sure g5 maybe he
wants to play Bishop g5 and then capture
on his heaven just getting rid of his
bishop I oh ok yeah I'm not going to
take that just just stay solid I might
have a sec sound probably we not want to
get out of the pin f6 is a move that
comes into consideration if he is not
reacting in some way now yeah I mean
reacting I mean something like that a
concrete move on night XA 5 the OS were
ideas like bouquet five I just don't
want to spend time to calculate that
just want to want to be masala tea on on
the queenside I can try
I can do something like that actually
I don't mind if he takes that this is
something that I don't mind at all then
I get the free a pawn okay get the a
porno I'm going to use it an idea is to
me let's let's do this just g6 make this
totally solid and now I pushing the
apron look c7 as an additional idea
covering f7 let's do that cover f7 and
now I'm I'm pushing stuff why not here
we go the a pawn is my winning pawn I
hope 93 at work takes me six so this was
a bit early yeah this is some model game
for this line this is the kind of ideal
scenario that sometimes happens if
everything works out to perfection from
black okay a two or maybe trading one
rook is a good idea
okay so i can take take the two on not
know then be sixes again hanging so I
have to check here first right and what
now what is the best now maybe taking on
d 2 and queen a form the checking and
I'm or queen a 4 immediately
okay let's not fall asleep here just
playing with it will be better for black
in some some way anyway but couldn't
really determine the best possible
continuation okay that plane night be
true and Quincy to our see how is he
actually defending the seat upon I don't
really see how
this smooth isn't c3 just falling and
with it the whole position white reason
yeah I guess it does yeah this was this
was the kind of ideal scenario for black
in this line we get trait that get to
trade the light squared bishops and why
does not really getting anywhere one
issue is that you very often want to do
this mean we're so that there's more
pressure on the night the way it went I
think when you when you come to come to
this the situation here black is already
a bit more comfortable and did this
emphasize move by move with all those
moves that do then don't do very much I
think I could have played better even if
we think about this here here yeah here
maybe I should have played this 97 f 5
earlier so that even the bishop is not
getting traded it's not terrible or
anything that that it was traded but
that's good smell funny funny evaluation
by the West stockfish who gives a wide a
slight advantage which is kind of funny
because I mean seriously why it can
never be better here because I can just
stay I mean just for argument's sake and
said say I do nothing why it has no palm
break here nef for I go g6 and block the
Kings side and he's never ever going to
do something on the queenside on the
contrary in a situation like that I just
have da porn I think here widest is
basically a yeah I mean it's really
close too close too close to being lost
and FY is kind of the end of it yeah
because now I'm totally safe on the
kingside night f4 or something was more
interesting this kind of idea putting
some pressure on the porn and here was
just the a porn is this is winning the
game I think
now taking and Korean c6 also was strong
word yeah this is this is this is just
winning winning in the house minus 10
that's quite quite a lot yeah it was
this was the kind of position you want
with the line so probably interesting to
watch for people are interested in this
this kind of sub line of the win over
okay thanks for watching